Les prêtres sont back dans le game bébé
Oui les baptêmes c’est notre fierté
On fait la messe avec trop de style
On rajoute du swag dans ton ostie
C’est nous les rois mages des temps modernes
On a même des snaps de la Sainte Vierge
Si t’approches de l’autel obligé tu danses
Pour la teuf on n’a pas fait vœu d’abstinence
Eau bénite, Eau bénite,
On fait même des baptêmes dans la street
Eau bénite, eau bénite,
Easy on en boit des litres
Au nom du Père et du Fils
Dans le diocèse on est numéro 10
Venez confesser tous vos vices
Viens au catéchisme
On va te faire vivre un dream
Avance dans l’église les yeux sont rivés
sur toi
On va te laver tes péchés
C’est tellement swag d’être purifié
Yeah yeah yeah yeah
Baptisés comme jamais
Christine et Boutin
Catho na Chapelle